bonjour la décision n'est donc pas
annulé mais regardez le 11e bataillon
des chasseurs alpins disparaîtra de
barcelonnette mais pas avant que des
mesures d'accompagnement ne soit trouvée
c'est ce qu'a appris officiellement hier
la délégation d'élus par 6 à paris
rencontrer le premier ministre
ces élus voulaient l'annulation de la
décision de jean pierre chevènement ils
ne tiennent donc que le report reste
maintenant à trouver ses solutions de
remplacement hugues girard nosy ce qui
est envisageable et surtout à quelle
condition
tous les projets de développement de la
vallée de l'ubaye passe obligatoirement
par la route départementale 900 la seule
voie d'accès vers le sud
cette route est pour l'instant un
véritable frein trop étroites tortueuses
le conseil général et le conseil
régional vont mettre de l'argent pour
l'améliorer les travaux devraient durer
environ trois ans la route refaite la
vallée de l'ubaye pourra redevenir
attractif pour toutes sortes d'activités
en général liés au tourisme qu'il soit
d'été ou d'hiver
l'été la vallée à plus de 1000 mètres
d'altitude est un véritable paradis pour
tous les sports en eaux vives sur le
bail pour tous les randonneurs aussi
certains ont même imaginé des randonnées
thématiques autour du fort de tourner où
par exemple qui est un des joyaux de
l'architecturé militaire de montagne du
19e siècle
tout autour de la vallée il y a des
dizaines de fort plus ou moins
abandonnée qui pourraient être mis en
valeur à mettre en valeur aussi le col
du reste fonds et la cime de la bonette
c'est le col le plus haut d'europe de
1800 mètres d'altitude la route qui y
mène est devenue dangereuse presque
impraticable faute d'entretien en hiver
barcelonnette n'a jamais vraiment su
profiter de la proximité des stations de
ski comme pra loup et le sauze un peu
plus loin la foux d'allos
les élus de la vallée est ce les
stations ont pris maintenant conscience
que leur sort était lié et qu'il serait
temps grand temps même de créer des
syndicats intercommunaux les aides de
l'état
viendront d'autant plus facilement que
tous les élus de la vallée de l'ubaye et
du département seront d'accord sur un
projet de développement commun la crise
liée au départ inéluctable du 11e bca
pourrait faciliter la réflexion
une prise de position ce matin le bureau
du comique